hey Travis
look who decided to call has there been
another murder uh-huh uh uh actually
eat meat with that a neat rom-com sequel
this is not a sequel
number one suspect is the bride Zoe's
sister
Grace didn't do it we got a dead body
and a whole lot of talk to what's your
name you fine as hell Travis
we'd like to hear your accounts of what
happened I like to call them your mind
movies
she was all trouble and for the record
the case wasn't the only thing that was
hard oh God
everyone here had a motive
many tales to tell actually maybe they
just start from the beginning of the
wedding I'm a Searcher okay
Edgar is a crumb and Grace knows that
I'm
was that pretty handy with a broom that
was a broom that's how I could tell
you've never swept before it's like a
lightsaber
[Music]
well it's actually my adoption day I
don't know when I was born
this looks delicious that's potpourri
bon appetit
we know you're eating air freshener
anyone could have done it
my mother says hello
[Music]
she went to be here but she was busy
with silence and alcohol
let us raise the toast to the happy
couple this whole thing is so much more
complex than you guys realize
[Music]
well I think it's pretty clear we've got
our guy what did you say you got or not
not what
[Music]
killed Edgar
s
rich white people whisper is never a
good thing